Jean-Philippe Hughes.
- La justice aide toujours.
- La diaspora libanaise a soif
de justice. Les souvenirs
du 4 août 2020 sont toujours
aussi douloureux.
PASCALE CHAÏB,
copropriétaire Andalos
- C'est triste et c'est dommage
qu'un pays aussi beau
que le Liban souffre autant.
(explosion)
- La déflagration est à glacer
le sang, plus de 2ibibibanais
meurent dans l'explosion
aux abords du port de Beyrouth.
Plus de 6000 personnes sont
blessées. Les enquêtes stagnent
et n'ont toujours pas apporté
les réponses attendues.
LEILA MALAK, vice présidente
finances, Andalos
- Ce qui m'attriste le plus,
c'est que après deux ans, toutes
les enquêtes qui ont été faites
ou pas faites ont abouti à rien.
On ne sait même pas qui est
le coupable, on saitn.n.n.
- L'onde de choc, en plus
de faucher des vies humaines,
a du même souffle balayé
le poumon économique du pays.
SAMI AOUN, UdeSherbrooke, dir.
Observatoire Moyen Orient UQAM
- C'est une descente aux enfers,
presque littéralement.
La pauvreté s'est vraiment
élargie jusqu'à touch
à la hauteur de 80 %
de la population libanaise.- Lat
en chute libre et l'inflation
de certaines denrées de base
atteint les 40 %. Les Libanais
font face à des pénuries de
médicaments. Les interruptions
de courant ponctuent
le quotidien des gens.
- Tu stototous les gens
sont tristes.
- Toufic Hamzeh, 26 ans, s'est
lui-même résigné à fuir son pays
l'an dernier. Il laisse derrière
lui la pâtisserie qu'il avait
fondée afin de poursuivre
des études en génie à Montréal.
TOUFIC HAMZEH,
étudiant en génie à l'ETS
- Tu peux pas rester dans
un pays qui est comme ça,
dans un pays que tu ne sais pas
ce v v va se passer demain.
Même si tu as des plans pour
faire une meilleure vie pour
ton pays, pour ta famille.
- Commi,i,i, ils seraient plus
de 300 000 Libanais à avoir
quitté en deux ans, en quête
d'une vie meilleure.
- À cette cadence-là, c'est
quelque chose vraiment qui est
appeurant, parce que ça pourrait
faire saigner le pays
de sa force de jeunesse.
- Est-ce que vous comptez
retourner vivre au Liban
un jour?
- Je ne pense pas.
C'est terminé pour moi.
- Pas plus tard que cette
semaine, un silo de grains'est t
de Beyrouth, signe qu'un nouvel
accident n'est jamais bien loin.
Le deuxième anniversaire
de la tragédie sert de devoir
de mémoire.
- Essayer le plus possible
de garder cet événement vivant
dans notre mémoire, dans notre
conscience, pour effectuer
un changement.
- C'est en se serrant les coudes
que la diaspora traverse
lentement cette crise, qui
semble aujourd'hui s'enliser.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.